no one has ever done that so what has
has not done that in the history of dota
what sort of play could possibly have
caused such a reaction what sort of play
could be worthy of such praise it was
bold it was innovative it was completely
and utterly insane this is no tidehunter
roshan bait from dreamhack winter 2012
[Music]
it's the grand finals of dreamhack
winter 2012 an unspun surd local team no
tidehunter were up against the American
powerhouse Evil Geniuses
against all odds no tidehunter not only
topped their group but made it all the
way to the grand finals without dropping
a single map it's the biggest game of
the dota 2 cap probably the biggest map
of the European 32 circuit at the moment
and fantastically both 80 and no title
you led by seasoned veterans Lodha and
okay the team was mostly made up of
inexperienced players fielding the likes
of s for admiral bulldog and eternalenvy
in true David versus Goliath fashion
their opponent Evil Geniuses or a Titan
of the dota scene that featured
established stars like Malc demon and
fear the competition the period it's
really insane actually because the way I
see it no one no one that I know of can
predict the winner on paper no
tidehunter shouldn't have given EG too
much trouble and Game one seemed to
follow that script after eg lost their
group stage match against the new squad
they seem to have figured out the Swedes
play style making short work of them in
the rematch totally biggest thing like a
small amount of damage who is the one
being chased vs well gee ma just swapped
out one in admiralbulldog girls versus
the Mexican of last night pick up the
better man to beat is and it's going to
be a gg call coming out from eternal
Envy and the rest of team and Evil
Geniuses will take the game blood
following their decisive 35-minute when
Evil Geniuses appeared poised to take
the title and shut the door on no tide
hunters underdog story
the Swedes needed to come up with
something to shift the momentum back
into their favor and they need
it's soon after all necessity is the
mother of all invention but no one could
have expected what came next Apple
Bulbul given a freebie and here we go
uh-huh game is on Lucius this is
Saturday is Lane there's a small blood
patch where Admiral bull into traffic
and it is exactly trust because they
came to check for it now thus gone
bigger is that I know they're gonna
bring it down
oh my games now will the beat is this we
may pull something out of the bag and
Pete is going to go down as well Oh guys
hunter water stop what is going to be
coming out from Italia Lambie the profit
baby doesn't lose any gold anything
spice to inciting to Russia
it's a pure obey either menthol is gold
on starting on an entity no trying to
just come right out get to kill brought
up the back no one has ever done that no
one is ever Sam not in the hips ring a
soda with Toby wands from a legendary
words echoing through the venue no
tidehunter pulled off what is now known
as the roshan bates rocketing them to an
early lead and sending the crowd to
their feet to this day that play is
still one of the most clever and most
unique plays in DotA's lengthy history
to start off we were trying to do a
level one rush but then we came up with
better idea that's what I've done using
Admiral Bulldogs intentional suicide as
Bates n-th convinced eg that they were
attempting to do a sneaky level one
Roche the play the grand final and also
an immense toast again one and then
again so has the god to the Memphis but
we had like a 30 minute break so there's
like are we going to do guys where's
down one game we're playing is easy and
so I always came up with a set to get
the momentum you know it again with two
early kills under their belts and Iggy's
momentum waned the roshan bait put nth
in prime position to reclaim control of
the series and they made sure to jump on
the opportunity
hoisting the trophy high above their
heads
no tidehunter secured their place in
dota history by not only winning the
title at a major event despite not
having a sponsor but for doing so while
pulling off one of the most creative and
effective tricks in eSports history
while new inventive strategies are
continually pushing the boundaries few
can match this 1/nth had the audacity to
pull off the bait in the grand finals
against a veteran team and their
execution was flawless
is that good prep because I came to tech
for it now the son big guys that I know
that gonna bring it down it might have
happened really early in dota twos
history but the roshan bait still stands
as one of the game's most memorable
moments time has passed other plays have
come and gone but something about the
roshan bait has caused it to remain it
ever does not know what it has but tom
not in the history of dota maybe it's
toby wands perfect call maybe it's the
underdogs pulling off an unlikely
victory against a perennial powerhouse
or maybe it's that for one incredible
moment
no tidehunter proved that's the only
limit to what is possible is your
creativity these boys the boys nobody
had actually heard of a couple months
ago are setting their ways thanks for
watching if you want more great content
be sure to hit that subscribe button